let's pick up on our caller from C why
don't we go to the three three six area
code who's been holding on for nearly
forty minutes three three six what's on
your mind today hi David let me guess
that is okay so I'm Joel from Washington
and I understand there's a two-party
system United States was pretty
ingrained in our history yes I can't
help but feel a lot of the Americans
specifically the moderates will
reluctantly vote for one side easily
citing the lesser of the two evils
argument and I feel like it's a problem
that I'm just not satisfied for when I'm
voting and you know I just have one side
that I don't really appreciate like
certain things they have but I think
certain things might be a good idea and
I just don't feel like the tea party
system encapsulate everything let's take
it there's a lot there so let's just
deal with that a little bit so it's
there's the lesser of two evils but it's
also often by voting third party you're
actually helping the candidate who is
most different from your views to win so
what we would want to look at there is
something like single transferable vote
for example or a variety of different
systems that that's number one number
two are you are you thinking that like
are you saying you're sort of neutral
between left and right like there's some
things you like about the left and some
things you like about the right I would
say I've way more left on my politics
generally but there's not every single
thing I would agree on and I feel like a
two-party system doesn't really do that
for me no I totally agree with you but
it's not like you're sort of in the
middle where you you agree with enough
of each side where it's a tough thing
for you to decide who to vote for right
it sounds like you still no vote for
yeah yeah well listen I mean I agree
with you with the problem of the
two-party system for sure but I I
sometimes I'm concerned when people say
you know the left and right they both
have some ideas I like and some I
dislike and it's hard for me to know who
to vote for because for most people the
things you would like about one side are
often much outweighed by the things that
disgust you about that side I wouldn't
even say like a lot of things on the
right I just there's some things I'm not
too fond of on the left either right all
right that's what it's not like the
right has
better what don't you like on the left
what don't you like on the left well I
don't exactly agree with everything to
do with abortion I think it should be
like only a first trimester thing okay
but that's just my opinion I and I know
people disagree and that's fine and what
about cases of them like where the life
of the mother is at risk yeah I would
say that's fine them do you think I
would I'm pretty open to evolving on
different issues I just you know there's
not I I agree with flexibility on right
do you think you might feel differently
about the abortion issue if you were the
type of person by that I mean a woman
that might ever need an abortion
probably you would okay interesting
interesting well that might make me
reckon reconsider my opinion if I if I
had that that sort of awareness okay
thank you so much I really appreciate
the call all right thanks all right very
good